this is a production of Cornell
University
okay good morning everybody and thank
you for taking the time to come to to
this talk is my pleasure to tell you
some of the work where we have been
doing for the past probably 10 20 years
already in regards of understanding
what's the function structure and how is
the regulation of a particular set of
membrane transport proteins that mediate
response response to tolerance of a
particular set of abiotic stress what
I'm showing you here is a world maps a
heat map of the density of crop areas
nowadays in the world it's pretty clear
come on okay when you look at the the
soils the suitability of soil is pretty
clear that there's a nice correlation
where there's a high density of
agriculture taking place with the
quality of the soils around the world so
there's no big surprise we basically do
agriculture where the soils are good
however when you take into account that
by 2050 our population is increasing by
about twenty-five percent and just in
about 20 years or so we need to increase
our production by forty percent it's
obvious that we have to start thinking
about moving into this marginal soils
and it's start increasing the
productivity that is currently taking
place in this sort of marginal soils
where the soils are not suitable for
agriculture so this marginal soils are a
result of several abiotic stresses
including droughts salinity and also
aluminum toxicity and to tell you why
aluminum toxicity is such an important
abiotic stress or first overlap a heat
map describing the pH of the soils
around the world acidic ph s are shown
in red hmmm so in terms of the total
area of the world about thirty percent
of the total soils in the world are
acidic and that constitutes about
seventy percent of the potential V
arable lands are
the world which includes the south the
south and tropical band which takes into
account particular regions where food
food supply in food stability is more
tenuous at the moment so why is aluminum
toxicity or curing this in this kind of
acidic soils aluminum is pretty harmless
at neutral in basic ph's because it's
bound to to the oxide in the silica and
the soil however when you start hitting
low pH is acidic ph s aluminum's to
liberalize this into the solution and as
the pH becomes more acidic what happens
is the predominant form that you will
find a fallu manam in the solution in
the rhizosphere is al three plus and
it's this particular form of aluminum
which is actually phytotoxic to plants
so I have them so how toxic is it really
let me just show you a couple of
examples these are two maize varieties
grown in the south and part of Brazil in
acidic soils as you can see there's an
aluminum resistant variety and aluminum
sensitive the sensitive variety actually
has a significant loss of yield like was
this is two contrasting varieties from
wheat the aluminum sensitive variety
what you can see is a really dramatic
inhibition or loss of the root growth
and that's the primary that's the
primary symptom of aluminum toxicity
aluminum as soon as you expose the roots
to aluminum the root growth ceases what
that results in is a loss of water
uptake loss of mineral uptake and
ultimately but what it translates into
is loss of yields so this is just a
micrograph showing you the degree of
injury that roots actually experience
upon exposure to aluminum these aren't
the same wheat varieties I'm showing you
right here so fortunately there is a
generic variation in crop plant species
which we can exploit to understand what
are the physiological mechanisms that
underlie this this aluminum resistance
process
and for most crops what has been founded
was early described back in the early
90s is that those aluminum resistant
varieties actually upon exposure to
aluminum the roots really release
organic acids into the rhizosphere what
this organic acids do is they complex
the aluminum they chelate it in the form
complexes that a are not toxic and B are
not taking up by the root that way there
excluding aluminum from coming into the
root system and have its phytotoxic
events so as I said this was originally
described in weight subsequently we
describe it in maize but has nowadays
being reported as a very highly
conserved mechanism throughout a whole
variety of crop species so overall
aluminum resistance in plants can be can
be achieved by an exclusion mechanism
such as the one I just described which
is the release of organic acids into the
rhizosphere forming non-toxic complexes
or true tolerance or detoxification
mechanisms if aluminum is able to get
across the across the plasma member of
the root cells it can form complexes
with organic acids which are sequestered
into the vacuole of the roots and stored
there in a non toxic form or in some
cases it can actually be loaded into
Asylum translocated into the into the
shoots which sequestered it and this is
the case of plants which are aluminum
hyper accumulators such as the case of
of tea crops so for the purpose of this
talk all I'm focusing on is what I'm
going to talk about is aluminum
exclusion mechanisms and particularly
i'm going to talk about this two
transporters or the nature of this
transporters here
so the mayor breakthrough in terms of
understanding what was the molecular
identity of the transport is mediating
this really sort of organic acids came
back in 2004 about 10 years ago bye-bye
Sasaki at all in Japan and they
basically cloned a novel transporter
which they called aluminium activated
male a transporter or a LMT in weeks in
2004 in 2007 Liam's group actually
called the second aluminum autonomous
gene and what they found out is there is
an additional transporter or an
additional family of transporters the
clone it from sorghum and it's a family
of transporters from the multidrug toxic
compound extrusion family or mates these
two transporters are very different in
terms of their secondary structure the
structure and the way they function
these are predominantly an ion channel
type of transporters while this are sort
of anti porters so in terms of signal
transduction it's a very complex network
of signal transduction cascade which
basically the aluminum stress is sent
and there's a whole bunch of
transcriptional regulation going on
which ultimately affects the expression
of these two transporters dln T's in the
mates however what I'm interested in
talking about today is how are these
transporters actually post translated
regulating in other words i'm not
interested in finding out what's what's
the gene ID to live at the gene level
what is the transcriptional regulation
of these transporters but the protein
itself how does it work how does it
mediate the release of organic acid in
can the protein actually respond by
itself to the presence of extrasolar
aluminum so i'm going to focus today on
the LM TS and i'll leave the the mate
story for another opportunity so the
wheat ale mt was cloned back in 2004 and
it said it was the first alien t
characterized at that time and does they
gave it the name of
aluminum activated male 8 release
channel since then we know that they are
expressing the root tips and
subsequently we and other groups were
involved in the cloning of a málaga
among genes to LMT one which these genes
are in fact involved aluminum resistance
they mediate the release of organic
acids and their associated with the
aluminum resistance response however
nowadays we know that the LMT family is
not just an ion channels involved in
aluminum resistance but they're involved
in other physiological processes there
are a MTX that are expressed in guard
cells so they're involved in in the
regulation of guard cells there are
there a limit eased are they are
expressing roots and they are involved
in the mineral nutrition and general
uptake from a phylogenetic point of view
from the genome sequence projects we're
able to establish that the L&T family is
pretty much divided into five different
clades with the set of aluminum
resistance related alien teeth belonging
to clade one now this is the only set of
LM TS thus far that has been
functionally characterized this is just
based in the genome sequencing projects
from a secondary structure point of view
most able entities have a conserved
structure which consists of the first
half of the protein contains about six
transmembrane domains with the other
half of the protein being more
hydrophilic and containing a it's about
half of the protein which is a highly
hydrophilic region which I'll talk later
about so giving the similarity in the
structure of all this a limb tease what
we're interested in finding out is what
makes a given a linty like this a LMT
that is related to the aluminum
resistant phenotypes that we observe
we know that there are some alien tees
there are actually expressed in roots
but they're not related to the aluminum
resistance so there must be something
about this particular set of alien tees
that allow them to confer aluminum
resistance phenotype implants so for
this purpose what we've been doing is
we've been doing structural and
functional analysis of particular of the
the weed LMT one what we do is we use a
functional we use extra logs expression
in all sides what we can do is we can
generate we can express that the
transporter we can generate using
conventional molecular biology tools we
can generate different chimeras or
single point mutations locations and so
on just express them in the Oh sites we
can generate CRNA we inject the CRNA
into the oil side cell which is about
one millimeter in diameter so it's
really convenient in terms of doing
microinjections this cells express the
CRNA they translated the place your
transporter in the cell and you can
perform either functional studies using
conventional electrophysiological
techniques such as two electric voltage
clamp or you can do structurally
structure studies using taking advantage
advantage of different fluorochromes
what this allow us to do is perform the
functional and structural studies set
hypothesis in terms of we are expecting
in terms of the relation of the
structure to the function of these
transporters and test test our
hypothesis by generating different
versions or structurally modifying the
LMT and seeing what its impact in the
functionality of that transport protein
is so first giving the let me just take
you back one slide given the fact that
this LMT mediates the release of organic
acids upon exposure to aluminum what
we're interested to see first was what's
the interaction of aluminum with the
actual transporter and for that reason
the first step we have to take is to
determine what is the topology
LMT across the plasma membrane is this
side facing the cytosol exciter is it
facing the Apple Apple plasmic side up
of the membrane in terms of which is the
part of the protein that first sees the
aluminum experiences the presence of of
the l3 plus so to carry on the membrane
topology studies of LMT what we have
developed is a technique where we have
taken advantage of the pH sensitivity of
the GFP in such a way that the intensity
of the fluorescence of the emission of
the GFP is ph-dependent such that when
you start hitting acidic ph s the
emission of the GFP or the intensity
sched down its reduced so what we first
developed as a method where we can
monitor the intracellular ph of the old
site using a small pH microelectrode so
we impale those cells with the ph micro
electrode and we establish a set of
extracellular solutions which we profuse
on the outside of the oil side and
measure the changes in pH that occur
internally in the outside and this is
what we observe that we change the
extrasolar pH from 7.5 through 7.5 plus
sodium acetate or extras are pH of 5 we
maintain a relatively constant
intracellular ph however when we put so
do L extrasolar solution of ph 5 plus
sodium acetate sodium acetate is a weak
acid which dissociates at ph 5 permeable
is the membrane of the old side gets
inside ink and yields this interest or
acidification be all set so having
established this methodology we look at
what's what's the change in a relative
fluorescence of the GFP through this
this set of solutions what I'm showing
you here is a compochia image of at the
edge of the other side as it's being
bath through this different set of
solutions so at 7.5 is it running yep
basically that the intensity of the GFP
doesn't change and as soon as we put in
5.0 + sodium acetate what
we obtain is a question of the GF b so
we have a nice system where we can
correlate changes in in the intensity of
the gfp with changes in interstellar ph
so that we can use that as an indicator
potentially where where is the GF be
found in this case obviously the soluble
gfp is found in the interstellar space
we did the same with a particular
transporter a teammate by tagging it in
the n-terminus with the gfp and what we
obtained is a similar pattern to that
described with a soluble gfp we know
that that that the n-terminal domain of
the a teammate is located in the inside
so we have a good indication that our
technique is working now we use a
negative control using opt three they
transported that we heard about early
this year a talk given by Elena and we
tagged it at the c-terminus we know that
thank you we know that the c-terminus of
that transporters is located to the
outside and just as you would expect
when you bath it through the different
set of conditions we have there's no
change in the first two solutions but as
soon as there's ph5 in the extra solar
space we quench the gfp so we have a
nice system to show to basically use the
gfp of an indicator of is that
particular n-terminus or c-terminus okay
to the interstellar space or the plasma
face of the transporter using this
approach we took our gene of interest
the wheat ale and t1 we first tag it in
to see in the n-terminus and what we
obtain is pretty much the similar
behavior to what we obtained for the
soluble gfp indicating that this
particular gfp here is facing where it's
located in interest or space of the cell
we've taken the same approach with
transporters tagged at the c-terminus we
know that the c-terminus actually
located in to the inside of the cell we
know that the end of the transmembrane
domain 6 is also located to the inside
of the cell and there was some
controversy about the potential
existence of additional transmembrane
domains around this region what we've
done is we've taken the gfp and we
flanked those different transmembrane
domains
we found that the GFP is located towards
the inside indicating that there's no
transmembrane domain region there even
though it might be a highly hydrophobic
region it might be involved in the
anchoring of the protein rather than
actually constituting a domain which
transverses the delivered by layer
so having to establish the topology of
the protein the next thing we were
interested in understanding is how does
the protein assemble thus the the
channel work as a single subunit so one
single subunit of a LMT is functionally
active or the citta semble as a
multimeric transporter in such a way
that you require the Assembly of several
subunits to form the actual functional
channel for this purpose we have USB IFC
pretty much a well-established technique
by now we've tagged subunits of a LMT
with the two complementary halves of the
yfp and what we get is complementation
of the yfp at the plasma membrane
indicating that a LMT the LMT subunits
are actually interacting we've also
tagged the subunits in opposite
directions with half of the the YP
attached to the end the other half
attached to the c terminus and we also
obtained complementation suggesting once
again that the c terminus and the
n-terminus are facing the same in the
same compartment the cytoplasmic of the
cell so we know that the LMT subunits
interact the next thing where we were
wondering is what's this documentary of
L&T so our two subunits interacting or
is the transporter consisting of three
or four subunits interacting for this
purpose we're collaborating with a basic
of lab in UC Berkeley and what they use
is they use turf microscopy to address
this particular question so the first
step we had to do was prove that their
technique actually it's suitable for
starting plaque membrane transport it's
not just just suitable for starting
animal channel transporters so what we
did is we tagged cat one with a GFP cat
one is a potassium channel from
arabidopsis and there's there's good
knowledge about the structure in the
assembly of of this type of potassium
channels but we've shown is that the
functional properties of the intact cat
one resembled those of the cat tagged
with a GF b so the addition of the GFP
is not affecting the functionality of
the transport
when we express that transporter in all
sides and in a low density under the
turf microscope where you can observe
it's actually single gfp molecules that
are being further bleached single Single
gfp molecule emissions when you look in
detail to a particular set of those
single spots and I'm just going to show
you want to focus on on this red region
here what we can do is we can actually
measure the changes in intensity that
take place in that particular spot as
the as the GFP is being quenched by by
the laser so basically what we get is a
high intensity point and as the GFP is
being bleached you lose the signal and
that's what being quantified here over a
period of about 20 seconds now what you
see is that the change in intensity
actually occurs in four very discrete
steps it's not a continuous behavior but
you have four different steps or
discrete changes what that is telling
you is that you actually have for gfp
molecules that are meeting in that
particular spot for gfp molecules each
one attached to one of the subunits of
cat one in other words what that
stealing is in every single spot that
you look at what you're finding is cat 1
assemble as a tetramer consisting of the
four subunits and this is what actually
forms the functional transporter of cat
14 subunits assemble in such a way that
this this region in the middle actually
consists of the permeation pathway or
the poor of the transporter so knowing
that we can actually use this technique
for for plant cells what we did is we
implemented it for the ailing t1 in
other LMK teas and what we obtained is
that the transporters actually assemble
as a dimer
so this is the functional state of the
transporter we've done this for not only
the weed LMT we know that it that also
happens for the arabidopsis for the maze
L&T so apparently the dimer state is
construct throughout the entire alien t
family so what i've shown you so far is
those structural studies that we've done
basically just coming out from a
secondary structure we are able to know
more or less the topology of the LMT
across the membrane which part faces the
cytoplasm which part face the extras
other side we know there are symbols as
a dimer now what we're interested in
finding out are what are the functional
properties of this L&T and how do those
function with properties correlate with
the structure with the secondary
structure prediction so for that purpose
once again what we're doing is we're
expressing our protein of interest in
the old sites we're able to load the old
sides with the substrate in this case
may late we micro inject the cells with
male it a couple of hours prior to doing
the electrophysiological recordings and
we used to electric voltage clamp to
study the activity of that transporter
expressed across the plasma membrane to
put in simple terms what we do is the
cell is so big is one millimeter in
diameter we're able to impale to micro
electrodes on it with one micro lector
we are able to impose a voltage across
the plasma membrane of the cell with the
other micro electrode what we are able
to do is we're able to record the
currents that are elicited or that
happen at that particular holding
potential those currents are simply the
movement of ions across the plasma
membrane a current is just the transport
the transport of ions across the plasma
membrane so
let me show you what happens in control
cells by control cells I mean cells that
have not been injected with the RNAs who
they are not expressing the transporter
versus what happens with cells that have
been injected with the L&T transporter
so here I'm showing you a holding
potential of minus 100 millivolts this
is the magnitude of the current again
it's simply it just relates to the
amount of transport that's taking place
control cells show a very small current
very basal endogenous transport taking
place across the plasma membrane and LMK
tease in the absence of aluminium
mediated slightly larger transport in
those cells however what's really
important is that upon just adding
aluminium to the bath so if basically
you replace the back meeting for the
same solution but now it includes about
20 micro molar aluminum chloride what
you get is a very relatively quick it
happens within a couple of minutes a
very quick enhancement of the transport
activity mediated by aluminium bye-bye
LMT sorry so here basically we have a
transporter that is not at the
regulatory it's not at the transcription
level but actually just happens within
minutes so basically the transfer some
how it's sensing the presence of
aluminium the fact that aluminum
interacts with the transporter changes
it causes the conformational states and
it surrenders the transporter in a more
active state
so this is another way of looking at the
trans productivity of alien tease so
rather than holding holding the the
membrane potential for a long period of
time what we can do is we can just look
at the transport activity over a small
period of time of about 600 milliseconds
at a given voltage say minus 100 million
140 millivolts we measure the magnitude
of the transport at that particular
voltage and then we just keep changing
the holding potential to smaller and
smaller less negative holding potentials
and we keep measuring the transport
activity and those particular voltages
so once again these are just traces
superimposed or current magnitude
superimpose at different holding
potentials once again control cells show
a very small transport activity they
still have some transfer activity and
it's obvious it's it's the transfer
activity from the endogenous
transporters of the cell but when you
express a land TX you obtain a obtain a
magnitude of transport much higher which
is mediated by this transporter but most
importantly when you expose them to
alien to to aluminum to extracellular
Luminum what do you obtain is once again
an enhancement of the trance
productivity mediated by the ailing t1
channel I'm not going to go into the
biophysics of it but basically we can
perform or sort of analysis based on the
magnitudes of this current and the
different voltages and substrates that
we used which are what I want to
summarize is that we do know that the
LMT 11 as I showed you is enhanced by
the presence of extras are aluminum
second de mediates negative currents
which are actually the product of melee
moving from the inside of the cell into
the outside of the cell
so here we are we have a transporter
that mediates organic acid released just
like you would expect it in in roots and
most importantly it responds to the
presence of aluminum so we're studying
finding out what is it that determines
that aluminum enhancement property and
this is all I'm going to talk about for
the rest of the talking it's what are
the motifs or what are the parts of the
protein that are actually responsible
for sensing the aluminum the extra
surveys so what we have been doing is we
have no structure knowledge of the LMT
apart from secondary structure
predictions so we've taking originally
we took a crude approach which is we
started looking at truncations of the
protein so we started by removing the
terminal 19 amino acids and we express
that truncated version of the protein in
20 sides and we compared the transport
properties relative to the unmodified
protein so when you truncate the last 19
amino acids basically you get a
transporter where the transport
properties are not affected the same is
true if we remove up to residue 435 so
basically expression of the first 435
residues including this transmembrane
domains plus part of the sea tail
results in a transporter is functionally
active however when we remove five amino
acid as it's more from the terminal
region what we obtain is a transport
there is no longer functional we've lost
the activity of the transport of both
the basal activity of the transporter
and obviously as well as the enhanced
ability of the being hence ability
feature of the transporter we know that
the transporter is being targeted to a
plasma membrane so there's something
about the folding that has been lost
that surrenders the transporter
non-functional not surprisingly when you
keep doing more truncation surround the
c-terminal domain we obtain transporters
are basically non-functional what was
surprising was upon removal of the
entire c-terminal domain that long
hydrophilic tail what we obtained
say transporter that recovers its
functionality however just just the the
n-terminus domain being expressed being
functional it cannot be enhanced or it's
not responsive to the presence of
extrasolar aluminum so what that posed
what that but that is telling us is the
n-terminus domain this first half of the
protein underlies the permeation pathway
which is not surprising seeing that it
contains the transmembrane domains
forming the poor where the ions are
going to flow through across the bilayer
but the question is is this c-terminal
domain we know that it's not essential
for protein functioning but is it
actually a domain that determines the
aluminum enhance ability of the protein
so when we expressed a LMT we're able to
calculate a km for the aluminum enhance
ability of the transporter basically its
concentration dependent and around five
micromolar were able to get fifty
percent maximum activation or
enhancement of the transfer activity of
the LMT what that is telling us is that
that high affinity what it suggests is
basically aluminum being al three plus
most likely is binding to negatively
charged residues in the protein thus sry
gene well we're measuring the
conductance so basically we look at the
relationship between voltage and current
and the slope of that relationship
should tell you what the conductance or
the transport rate of the transporter
would be so is the basically the
conductance we obtain and a giving
aluminum activity over the maximum
conductance were able to obtain so what
that what that suggests is that al three
plus is most likely binding to negative
residues in the in the transporter so to
evaluate the role of the c-terminus of
the LMT what we did is we started
neutralizing every single amino acid
negative residue in in the c terminus of
the LMT by changing aspartic acid I to
asparagine or gluten
has it changing into glutamine so
basically we're neutralizing each one of
those residues we take each one of those
single point mutations we express them
in all sides and again we compare the
influence or the potential change in the
functionality of the transporter
relative to the non modified transport
the data I'll be prone you just is just
in regards to the responsiveness of the
transporter whooping how did that happen
Wow
where are we
talk about Creek
where's somewhere around there right
okay Jesus stay away from it
there we go so all the all I'm going to
be talking about is the changes in
aluminium responsiveness how much does
the responsiveness of each one of these
transporters changes relative to a wild
type which were calm we're calling a
hundred percent responsiveness so what
you can see is we we obtain a whole
variety of phenotypes in terms of the
percentage of enhancement which goes
from transporters that are a little bit
more responsive but overall most of the
single mutations or most of the
neutralization resulting transporters
with lower responsiveness with a couple
or a few transporters that have actually
lost the responsiveness to aluminum
another way of presenting in that data
is is this way in terms of the magnitude
of the responsiveness but this is just
to highlight that it's not a discrete
response but it's rather a very
continuous response so there are
interesting residues like 274 275 and
423 where we have actually lost the
responsiveness of the transporter and
it's very tempting and actually the
Japanese group proposed it initially to
say well we have identified the residues
where aluminum is binding to the LMT as
soon as we neutralize them aluminum can
no longer buy to the LMT thus is no
longer responsive to aluminum however we
know that that's not the case when when
you look at the distribution of those
particular residues throughout the
entire 400 or so sequences so far known
for the aluminum for the LM TS what we
see is that restitch is like 274 to 75
or residues like 423 are actually highly
conserved or entirely concerned
throughout the entire LMT family so most
of the sequences include 70s which are
not related to the aluminum al
resistance response so what we think
it's happening is among these residues
we have identified residue sir we have
mutated residues which are highly
conserved and there requires actually
for up
the required for protein stability and
proper functioning as a overall amt
family and they actually have nothing to
do with the aluminum binding to the
transporter or with the phenotype of
aluminium responsiveness to prove to
prove this this hypothesis what we did
is we look for highly conserved residues
throughout the entire family residues
which are not negatively charged such as
the tryptophan here to defend 283 and
what we've done is we've done a single
point substitution in that residue as
well as a residue to 18 or 431 but
basically what we show is if you're able
to substitute those highly conserved
residues what you end up with is a
series of transporters there are no
longer as functional as the original
alien team therefore we do believe that
this residues negative residues were
identified originally are more involved
in overall protein stability folding and
functionality rather than they having
something to do with the aluminum
response in the responsiveness phenotype
so the next question we wanted to
address was can we move then the entire
C terminal block and the entire
c-terminus block is the one responsible
for the aluminum responsiveness so we
have characterized several alien piece
this is the one I've been talking about
it's aluminum impassable we know that
the Alma log in arabidopsis also
aluminum has a bowl in the maze LMT one
is not aluminum in hanceville so what we
done and done is we've done that we've
swept the domains basically we take the
n terminus of this transporter and we
attach the in terms of this transporter
or we can take the in terms of this
transporter and attach the c terminus of
this transporter resulting in this web
domain in that way we've generated six
different swap domains we express the
cells we express this contracts in all
sides and we look at the changes in
function
t so just to summarize all the data in a
very colorful way here i'm showing you
once again the LM TS which are
responsive and dl empties which is not
responsible when you take the c-terminal
region of the responsive ailing T's and
you attach attach them to the n terminus
of a non responsibility when the
obtained is no aluminum enhancement
activity so just the c-block move to a
poor of a different transporter it is
not able to enhance the trans
productivity of that alien t likewise if
you take the c terminus from from the
non responsive one and you place it into
the n-terminus poor region of the two of
the weed and the arabidopsis what you
obtain is actually an enhancement of the
trans productivity which was quite
possible puzzling as we thought that the
entrance domain was not involved finally
when when you swept them among the two
responsible and responsive ones what you
get is in some instances is able to
recover it in the other construct it's
not able to recover it what that is
telling us that the nature of the
n-terminal domain which we had this
Carter originally is actually
determinant of aluminum enhance ability
so we decided to look at the nth term
domain in terms of the potential
negative residues associated with that
with that protein region and once again
we perform single point mutations and we
look at changes in phenotype once again
we obtain a very continuous changes in
phenotype relative to the aluminum
responsiveness we obtain several
residues which basically surrounded
surrender the transporter in a state
which no longer enhanced by aluminum I
forgot mentioning that all the single
point mutations that we've done actually
result in transporters which are
functionally active they mediate the
basal level what Vera sees their degree
of aluminium responsiveness however once
again when you look at this at the at
the residues at this particular residues
what we find is they are highly
conserved throughout the entire
t family so suggesting once again we
cannot attribute a role to this residues
to the aluminum responsiveness of the
protein but rather we think they're
involved in overall functioning and
stability of the L&T family so the
question is is it all lost was it a lot
of single point mutation analysis that
led us nowhere mmm we took a different
approach so far what I showed you is how
we try to correlate the changes in a
particular residue with the distribution
throughout the entire family based on
sequences from genomic efforts now what
we try to look the question we posed was
okay let's let's take a look at what
what's happening here in terms of the
functionality but are we able to find
any domain on the set of alien tees that
have been functionally characterized we
have three alien tees that we know are
responsive to aluminum and we have a set
of ale and teas that are not responsive
to a luminal can we find in sequence
alignments any particular domain that
might be unique to this setup penalties
and the answer is yes what we ended up
finding is a motif right at the
beginning of the protein right at the
extreme end at the end term we found a
motif that is associated and is found
uniquely in this set of alien teas which
are aluminum responsive so this are the
motif looks is basically a highly
conserved region of the first 12 amino
acids with a variable region between two
and up to 35 residues most interesting
when when you not now we're walking back
to the phylogenetic analysis and we say
okay let's look through all the
phylogenetic are through the 400
sequences that have been available at
the moment and see how this identified
motif is present in this clades what we
find is that out of the 403 sequences we
find 17 sequences that contain this
motif and interestingly that motif is
only contained
in sequences that belong to clade 1
which is the clade which accounts for
this particular transport so everything
seems to indicate that this motif might
be associated with the aluminum
responsiveness of a LMT and this is
current work that we're performing on
the lab what we've done is we have
removed that in that 35 amino acid motif
and we know that the L&T upon removing
this motif is no longer functional so
it's not well it's functional but it's
no longer responsive to aluminum however
if we remove the terminal eight eight
amino acids we know that is the LMT it's
still responsive to aluminum so we're
still looking into we try to dissect
which which of this entire motif
actually corresponds to the part or
contains the part that makes the protein
responsible and that's what we're
valuating at the moment a whole series
of of deletions of this motif also what
we're testing is we're taking that motif
and we're doing a swap domain on an LMT
which is not aluminum responsive to see
if insertion of this particular motif at
the n-terminus will bring back the
responsiveness of the protein so overall
summarizing what I've shown you is we
started with a secondary prediction of
the ln tease we've done some topological
work and some surf work indicating they
assemble as dimers we know the topology
is such that the both the end and the
sea domains are contained to the inside
of the of the protein what's still
puzzling is if aluminum is interacting
with the protein how come it's
interacting with domains which are
contained within the inside of the
protein right if the association of
aluminum is such that at neutral pH is
aluminum precipitators is a hydroxide
how come aluminum might be getting into
the cell and interacting with motifs
located in our region which is basically
neutral pH what we think is we have
identified regions which are involved in
the structural changes that take place
underlying the enhance ability of the
transporter however the regions we're
I've identified are not necessarily the
regions where aluminum is interacting
directly with the protein and all this
has been done with any real structural
knowledge of the LMT we have just done
it with secondary structure predictions
but we are in urge we need to get a
crystal structure that allow us to place
a special spatial structure a crystal
structure 3d model of the alien T's to
be able to overlap all the functionality
that we know to basically to elucidate
what are the molecular determinants of
the functionality of the LMT so the
other part that I never told you about
is the other family of transporters the
the main transporters which is a
complete different story there regularly
in a different way and hopefully one day
I'll get the chance to talk about it so
basically summarizing I've shown you
sort of a set of multidisciplinary
approaches that have allowed us to
initiate function structure analysis of
membrane transporters which are involved
or mediated particular abiotic stress
response this knowledge will allow us to
potentially identify the allele of
membrane transporters that are most
effective in conferring aluminum
resistance in crop plants and in the era
of genome editing it's it is pretty
plausible to propose that we should be
able with the knowledge of of what are
the domains that mediate aluminum
enhancement in a particular family of
transporters we should be able to
engineer this membrane transporters in
order to enhance their ability to confer
aluminum tolerance and thereby expanding
their usage in available marginal soils
so finally I just want to acknowledge a
lot of people that have been imported
involved at different parts of this
project first of all the old-timers in
the coaching lab thanks for all the help
technical help and the intellectual
discussions particularly I want to
acknowledge people from from my group
Allison are yellow and Armando who have
carried part of part of the work as well
as visiting scholars international
visiting scholars rotating students from
plant biology that have
liberated and added little bits and
pieces to the puzzle as well as
undergrads who have rotated during the
summer through the plant genome research
project that BTW i hosts over the summer
also collaborators Ingo ed they're
involved in the phylogenetic analysis as
I mentioned it is involved in turf work
Jeffrey Chang is our right hand man in
regards to fungal to the structure and
crystallization of transporters and Dave
snarling CUDA are involved in that other
work that I haven't present so thank you
very much I finally want to acknowledge
the funding from what used to be NRI
nowadays is the is the nefa grant and
thank you for your time have you
estimated the single channel conductance
from melee no we haven't with the
expression abilities I haven't done any
single channel because I looked at your
turf so you have some channel density
yeah the you can ask
and from your IV curves i guess a truly
may late Simone in per second so I
wonder if you could be in civilian a
correlation yes we haven't I haven't
done any single chat where from from
historical sites although there are not
familiar basically single channel is can
actually isolate a little patch with the
memory single quality measure the
transport rate but we did do was back in
the early two thousands we did a lot of
cash back
proto class remains and from that we
detect
characterized and I encourage these
intra solar ni
protoplast and we did single-channel
work I believe it was a conductor
20 to 30 people students in those are
conditions and what we know that that
channel isolated patches also what
depends on the presence
Papa patches quiet if you sink time
appears which is consistent with the
articulate but no I haven't done a
single chaplain to have Jeremy estimates
of the channel density from the turkey
no
so I'm curious I done getting Christmas
our job is to be a wonderful hostess but
in lieu of that if you look to see
whether that n-terminal domain that she
might identify his protection to be some
involvement
are there similar structures and
proteins involved can I binding that
not for that party
so there's something unique about that
domain yes it's pretty frustrating
you're super comfy
Christmas all you have to do is in
sequence threaded through those crystal
structures right those positions
destroy the t's chocolate heaven throw
just general domains it's a family
unique in its back
sorry all the more reason to get that
in deities no I mean yes there are a
couple of substitutions at least put
beep one religion
more for my sins
originally they had proposed with
working all sides that it was a function
difference about them but
so no which would be nice to have
I
questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu